now
how did you do it you can see how
they're going to introduce integration
by parts into this so there was your
first step right um you start from this
left hand side
and the first thing you had to do was
identify an appropriate you and dv okay
so here's the way that i did it this is
the way i broke it apart
that gives you dude
uh by the way
things like that like that negative sign
right that's where you started to have
problems um and being that you were
required to show something this was this
happened lots and lots right you left
off a negative sign one which was needed
to get this result right but then
having left that off and then gone
through you're like oh no i've gotten to
some line which can't get to what i'm
trying to prove so you did some fudge
kind of down here that's got to be a
signal to you you've got to learn to
recognize that when you get down after
five or six lines and you're like i'm
not seeing it i'm not getting it i
should have a i've got a negative when i
should have a plus don't try and fluff
around down here and do a fix doesn't
work you've got to go back up clearly it
tells you you've done something wrong
like this okay so that's exam technique
for proofs like this
especially when there are a lot of marks
at stake okay right so you had x to the
m here which gave you v
okay so there you go there's all our
pieces so let's
do this um will that have enough space
now because it was a definite integral
um your uv part was actually being
evaluated from naught to one right so
this is what you started
there you go
okay so it's really nice and easy over
here because when you evaluate zero this
becomes zero so that's nice and when you
evaluate one this becomes zero which is
nice so that disappears but what you
cannot do just like with that previous
question with the definite identity uh
definite integral identity you can't
just make it disappear you have to say
it equals to zero okay so
little things um really you should have
said it's equal to zero minus zero
because there's two things there being
evaluated both of which are zero um
you've got a double negative happening
here so that's why this turns into a
plus
you can take out all your m and n terms
because they're just constants yes
so this goes from naught to one and then
you've got this guy
okay now
i think that's that's what we wanted
without the zeros at the front so that
part's done when you move into part two
all we asked to do um
they wanted you to use this part to get
to this expression for this recurrence
relation for i n right so how do you do
it how do you get rid of this guy in
here right well
you can start off from here and say
i am equals and clearly it's going to be
in here something in here is going to
have to interact with each other so you
can get that n power right so here is
where i went
i said okay we can say this from the
first part
okay now what can i pull out well i've
got an extra x here don't i right i've
got x to the power of n plus one so if i
write that in as x to the m times x
that's good right okay now that guy
there he's the key he's going to unlock
this whole thing right we just need to
need to get him in terms of one minus x
right hmm how am i going to do it
suggestions
take a seat
what do we make it equal to
minus
yeah what do i want i want a one minus x
out of this right i think probably the
easiest way is because i have this one
first i've got to add that in
right but if i've added that i have to
subtract it as well yeah
so if i if i subtract it this is what i
want to take away okay can you see the
ones going to disappear because it's not
really there right and those double
negatives will cancel leaving you back
with the original x right so we looked
at an example like this before in fact
we looked at the tricky one with like
threes and twos in and that kind of
thing okay so i think we should have
been able to spot this then you've got
your one minus x to the n minus one over
here okay can you see what's going to
happen
let's have a look so you've got n over m
plus one
there's your integral
okay what do we get um first you're
going to get i'll do it in this color
xam
times 1
times 1 minus x to the n minus 1 okay
that whole piece right so this is what
you get out of that
x to the m 1 minus x to the n minus 1.
okay i haven't split it apart yet
okay so there's the first part and i
know what that's equal to in terms of my
other integrals okay
then i've got this other guy to
factor out i've got x to the m
times negative 1 minus x
times 1 minus x to the power of n minus
1. right
okay so these one minus x's will come
together and with index laws that'll
become an m right so here's what you end
up with
um
let's chuck some big brackets around
that
there you go okay that was the critical
step once you saw that the rest of it
kind of falls out from there right what
happens you can split this apart into
two separate integrals so you've got an
n over n plus one here
what is this integral what is it in
terms of the notation that we've already
already introduced
this is um this is i of n minus one
isn't it you see that
bless you okay
then i'm going to take away i've still
got that n over m plus one out the front
but what is this
that's just i am cool
um and now i've that's the integration
done there right that's all equal to i n
now what did i want to do i want to make
i am the subject that's all right so
when you add this back over what are we
going to get
actually probably if we multiply through
that might make it a bit easier so
you'll have n plus 1 of these guys
n of these guys and n of these guys
kick that n over the other side so it's
going to become m plus n plus 1
of those
are you following did you see what i did
and now i just have to divide through
right uh yeah i've just got enough space
and over
okay
and there's the recurrence relation
hooray that wasn't so bad